did she regret showing you the ranger
video
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to a very special episode
of careful boys today we have with us Mr
Trump Nguyen hey
thanks for coming yeah appreciate you
guys man thank you for your service to
the country my friend I've known him for
a few years now he first popped up on my
explore page because like I would see
like these crazy [__] like dangling
feet with the helicopter machine gun
videos and I'm like who the [__] is this
guy and I clicked on him
crazy [__] he's like in [__] like
[__] rafts and [__] and like camo
paint and then I would see like oh
Chicago SWAT I don't know what the [__]
is the [__] SWAT team guy and then I
would like look more and like stocks and
more and I found out it was like a
former Army Ranger so I was like this
guy I have to follow like he's just
super cool and I DM them and they
actually told me that he grew up on JK
stuff wow that's so crazy that's so cool
the Uncle Sam era yeah yeah man
sometimes hey you turned out okay
well that's what made me when I see a
strong full-grown man that tells me he
watched JK I'm like man that's so weird
because I feel like I'm still in college
and you're like a full-on adult
I don't even think that I'm I'm that I'm
like damned I feel like a grandpa right
now I don't know like because we
probably have a 10-year difference huh
yeah I'm 30 I'll be 39 this year I'm 40.
you're 40. yeah Oh I thought you were 10
years younger then how did you watch our
stuff yeah I thought you're in Reverse
yeah
I grew up with you guys like running the
same age oh okay okay okay gotcha gotcha
so I was a teenager watching you guys
doing your thing I was like oh [__]
we're the same age yeah yes so he is
full grown adult no but then
okay we have fans who just like because
generally that's like 15 year apart yeah
like they're usually like 15 years
younger or 10 years younger that's why
I'm like damn that makes sense yeah
because you spend all this time in the
Army all this time in the SWAT teams so
if you just add those years together you
can't be 21.
you're a soldier with a 12 years old
we have challenge soldiers here too well
he's getting a maze yeah did you say
Chicago SWAT yeah
so like yeah can you explain explain
some of your story because I know you
were you also went to LAPD Academy right
yeah and then like your story is crazy
because you came here as a Vietnamese
Refugee and you did all this crazy [__]
probably better if you tell it to me how
old were you when you came to America
yeah so I came to America when I was
like three years old my mom fled the
Vietnam War because you know the north
overtook the South and it was a lot of
poverty and [__] like that going on down
there and our family was struggling so
they mustered together ten dollars so
they gave us what's equivalent to 10 US
Dollars we uh it was my my mom my two
sisters my two older sisters and myself
and we've fled Vietnam we stayed in the
Philippines for like a year
we lived there for like a year they in
process us then after that we made our
way to uh Chicago and I grew up in the
hood
majority of my life around gang banging
and all that [__] so
when when um you came to the States was
there like some kind of refugee sponsor
program that was that got you in or like
yeah because I know back then they they
would like be Christian families like
sponsoring Vietnamese families and they
lived together and stuff right is that
how it went down or so one one of my
sisters half white so she my mom hooked
up with a captain U.S army captain and
somehow I guess they worked out where
they can he helped her and and us over
there so but that's the that's that is
as far as he helped us out we literally
just got put into like a Section 8 home
so we just grew up they're all pretty
much all my life what made you join the
Army 911
uh so uh you don't go that's a terrorist
white person thing I'm gonna set this
one up
man
well if there's a third plane well if
we're basically the same age that means
this was all high school for us yeah
because when we went yeah when we went
to school that day they just rolled out
all the TVs and everyone was just
watching it every class so you were in
high school yeah I was finishing up high
school
um how I got started was my mom's best
friend her son was a lieutenant in the
Army he was an infantry officer he just
graduated Ranger school wow and that's
at that time we had VHS so they said
they sent her my her friend sent her a
VHS saying hey my son just graduated the
school your son should check it out so I
was sitting in the living room like a
piece of [__] got nothing to do and I
popped it in it was like Commandos
[__] Ranger school I was like oh [__]
this is dope as hell yeah yeah wow so at
the time you knew uh internet wasn't
prevalent you know we had AOL dial up
yeah so there's no [__] Google
there's none of that so I went to Barnes
and Nobles and I started doing my
research on the ranger regimen Rangers
and I got [__] so interested I was
like dude this is something I definitely
wanted to do so after 9 11 kicked off I
was like dude I'm gonna go [__] fight
man oh that's the thing that you needed
yeah did you were you physically fit in
high school already [__] no how did you
pass all that [__] oh man I was a
scrawny kid bro I was like a buck 25
soaking wet growing up I was like a hard
Gainer uh I just once once I decided I
signed a contract I just started pting
man P team physical training I started
working on my own and you know going to
GNC and and buying a weight gainer which
I only finished like a quarter of it
because it tastes like [__]
I remember that yeah so it was just
starch or just like yeah but you know
what's funny about the Army but the
military is that if you go when they're
skinny you come out heavier and if you
go in there heavy you come out skinnier
why because now they restrict you to a
three-course meal and you have to eat
the diet that they put so you just get
in the Middle with everybody but
everyone's eating the same thing working
out the same way so then everyone's like
yep were you were you double rations did
you guys have that double rations or no
so like for us uh when when you join
like in in our uh boot camp platoon like
let's say if you're fat they'll go half
rations and you'll have like a thing so
when you go to the child Hall yeah like
they they like that's a [__]
hilarious yeah when you go to the child
Hall and like let's say there's a
[__] Salisbury steak or whatever they
just cut it in half and give it to you
wow and then if you're skinny it's
double rations so I feel like if you're
like a buck 20 you walk up they'll give
you oh you get two and then our drill
instructor was so cool that um he was
like anybody that can do 20 pull-ups
gets double rations because then you
don't have to worry about your weight
like if you can pull your own weight 20
times it's a lot yeah so you just watch
the skinny people struggling to either
double rations while you're like
starving but then that's how people like
you know if they're skinny come out and
then did you get in trouble if you share
because like if you're dope if you're
half rations you're a fat dude and you
made a skinny homie and then you like
can I have like yeah sure it's it's I
don't know how army boot camp is but you
can't really talk yeah you can't [__]
talk because while you're eating like if
I'm eating and Nick's eating we only
have like five minutes
it's your [__] phone right now
you know like I'm trying and you're like
you put some on please are you just like
swallowing yeah yeah you can't be like
do you wanna [__]
yeah their big thing is eat it now taste
it later yeah and they're and they're
fine with it later and they're [__]
five minutes it's like really one minute
yeah five minutes I mean like 30 seconds
I remember the first day of boot camp
Bart
they [__] smoked the [__] out of us
all day smoking's like they you know
they make us do pt like get the [__]
down oh yeah you know just yeah throwing
dirt in your face spitting on you so
lunch time I remember getting a [__]
playful food I was like [__] yes I can't
wait to eat this thing I literally had
like 10 seconds they're like you got
five minutes the next thing is like 30
seconds five four three two get the [__]
up get the [__] up I was like I'm still
trying to [__] eat because the way
they count is like does it all right
everybody have 60 seconds whatever
that's not real
excuse me
can you use your iPhone so do you think
that without 911 happening you wouldn't
have gotten interested in the military
at all I think I would have eventually
joined but that really gave me the push
to join you earlier were you trying to
say big thanks because of 911 now he's a
military dude no I was gonna say that
because if you end up in Chicago and you
said you grew up around gang banging all
these negative influences yeah what
makes you ultimately decide
to do something that's true like fight
for the country yeah it's like if that's
kind of your environment how do you get
away from bro I'll tell you what man
like people say who you hang out with
matters is the [__] truth you know I
I'm not gonna say I was a perfect kid
growing I wasn't I was I was touching
school a lot I almost flunked I hung out
with the wrong crowd then I just read
one day just had a fork in the road I
was like if I keep hanging out with
these dudes I'm gonna be a [__] loser
one day or I'm going to go the other
route and try to change my life and
that's when I decided like you know what
no more you know my mom did went through
all this for me to come over to America
if I become a piece of [__] I'm not only
letting myself down but I'm letting the
most important person in my lifetime
which is my [__] mom so that's why I
changed my life around and went back to
school and got almost Straight A's wow
and though my mom was like you know I
typical Asian parents lawyer doctor
pharmacist whatever I was like yeah okay
so I snuck away at that time I was
already 18 years old I snuck away to the
recruiter and I signed the contract
behind her back oh [__] yeah so a month
before I shipped out I took uh my
girlfriend at the time my mom up to
Chinatown and we sat there and I was
like Mom I got something to tell you
just like what she pregnant I'm like no
no no no no
I'm going to the Army oh man she was
[__] she cried you're gonna [__]
die there's a war going on right now you
know what the [__] you do yeah bro
that's serious stuff
that's crazy yeah and then um didn't she
regret showing you the ranger video
at the time she [__] did like the old
man should have melt this [__]
[Applause]
why did I show him I influenced him so
out of after boot camp what was your
first like thing that you did like when
you were deployed and everything yeah so
I I had a ranger contract so a lot of
people don't know Ranger contract is
something you signed before you join
that guarantees you uh a a select to go
through the selection doesn't guarantee
you to make it it's on you if you're
gonna make it or not and maybe you can
explain the amount of so like the
Rangers is a very elite group of like
special operating like light duty
Airborne infantry yeah so to become a
ranger you have to go through a bunch of
schools so maybe you could explain like
all the schools yeah because then some
people think park ranger and some Park
Rangers think their actual Army Rangers
oh man but yeah
Bart is absolutely right uh there's a
pipeline that you go through you know
you go through basic uh boot camp then
you go to Advanced uh schools which is
some people are a schools depending on
where you're at for us it's called
Advanced uh infantry school so we stayed
there then we went through Airborne
School
how much time are these schools taking
so the the Infantry everything was about
14 to 16 weeks from there that's after
after initial boot camp yeah so that's
boot camp
Airborne school is three weeks that
sounds fun then after that at the time
everyone's cool yeah yeah yeah
real fun
yeah so uh [__] after that you go
through something it's called raps now
Ranger assessment selection program but
back then it's called Rip Ranger and
Doctrine program it was three weeks and
they smoked the [__] out I mean
worse like if you thought that was hard
that was not hard this is where they if
you want to be this this is where the
suck Fest really happens and that's to
almost kind of like your appetizer
before you go to Ranger school so what I
think the goal is like
because the government's going to spend
a [__] ton of money on you when you're
going to these schools so they don't
want to waste money right so they're
going to try to like filter you out so
this like pre-like school like rip or
rasp they're gonna [__] almost kill
you yeah and then if you pass then maybe
you'll pass this what's the percentage
of people that make it through that
round yeah so with rip and Brass what it
is is because a lot of people don't
realize Ranger school is a leadership
course
so as an infantry officer you have to go
to Ranger school so you can you go there
you earn your Ranger tab which is the
black and gold ranger but it doesn't
really make you a ranger because you get
you're going to go back to your unit uh
to be a ranger you have to go through
rip or wrath then you get your
tambourine then you get to Ranger scroll
so that that's your selection to get
into the ranger regimen which is like uh
three different regiments throughout the
United States uh once that's the
specialized unit the specialized unit
and the washout rate is is pretty
[__] high
uh we had when we started our class we
had like 180 soldiers I think we
graduated like 40 [__] dudes
that's the way do you guys laugh at them
like hey we made it
toughest part in that Journey for that
particular uh it's just you're you're
meant the mental game the mental and
physical game you know like everybody's
sucking at that point right but then you
have to dig deep and and to see if you
really want to be there
because a lot of people say they they
want to do something they do it it gets
hard they [__] quit but when you're
out there and it's like uh when I went
through it was winter time
and uh it was cold as [__] they had us
like you know out there in in a coal
range which is Infamous where they take
you to beat the [__] out of you pretty
much uh there was a bonfire they play
psychological [__] games with you
they build this gigantic [__]
bonfire with sleeping bags and and
they'll have like [__] hot dogs
they'll just sit there right and they
they don't let you [__] really eat
because you're making you hit the wood
lines you got to go [__] find
navigation points or make you do all
this [__] so you're you're up all day
getting your ass handed to you left and
right sleep deprived sleep deprived
you're holding a rucksack on top of your
head and they're like you can quit
anytime there's a bonfire you know goes
down
Rosa Marsh go grow some hot dogs and you
can smell it and some guys a lot of guys
quit oh and then you see them over there
crying roasting marshmallows it's just
this is how it starts I let myself down
man
this is how it starts it starts off
everybody don't want to be the first
person to quit yeah yeah but once that
first [__] drops off then then
just a trickle then that's like also
it's okay he quit I'm I'm [__] I'm done
too then you start seeing all your
buddies that you thought there's gonna
be a badass and start dropping left and
right then you really question yourself
like do I really want this plus it gets
harder because if you're in the select
few who haven't quit man like your
mentality at that point with just those
few lasts yeah different levels you
gotta want it yeah you know it's like I
always tell people you got to [__]
want it like more than the marshmallow
bored in the [__] marshmallow
that's hard I love marshmallows
marshmallows here's a question when
somebody fails uh like a thing like that
yeah are they allowed to just be like Oh
I'm just gonna go be a regular army guy
yeah so we're just talking about that
off camera what happens to those dudes
so the Army the Navy are
pretty smart on how they advertise like
oh you can become a Navy so you see all
these cool commercials right be a Navy
SEAL but the thing is their attrition
rate is so high and they know that so
that's like a they make these
commercials look all sexy yeah to bring
in all these [__] people to sign up
but you sign a contract three years five
years so now you're locked in so when
you [__] quit your needs of the army
needs of the Navy so whatever they need
you all the true we need 40 troops with
the 82nd Airborne they're going to send
them over there they need we need 10
troops with the third ID Infantry
Division we're gonna send them there we
need troops on their [__] uh the the
fleet for the Navy to [__] paint the
the boats yeah you're oh so they find a
use for you oh yeah you are they're not
gonna waste their money here like here's
a trumpet go play in front of the way
oh I always wondered about that yeah
you're you're locked in bro your Uncle
Sam's property so it's almost like it's
kind of like a gamble that's the scary
part as a recruiter it's like for you're
it's cool that you can lock in almost I
want to be a seal I want to be a ranger
in the beginning that's really really
cool but the gamble is if you don't make
it oh yeah then you are at the needs of
the army versus if you don't do that and
you do it stop step by step you can
almost baby step your way into it like
let's say you know what I'm just gonna
be a nurse in the Army and you can just
sign up for that but then like as you do
that you're like oh you know what I
think I can go up the ranks but then you
you don't have that direct to your like
pipeline you know right so it's kind of
like the give or take like do you want
something fast and now and guaranteed
but you may not make it and then then
anything is up for grabs for your job or
you want to go like the slower route but
then they'll have time so the real
school is like after you make it into
Ranger school right and then you have to
do the training to be a ranger so the
real the real school the real the real
Ranger is the rip and the raps because
then you go to the but here's the thing
to me I always tell people you think
that's selection that's not selection
when you get to the ranger regiment
that's where the selection starts that's
right after that yeah because that you
get to the unit either first second or
third ranger battalion those are three
right but the thing is when you get it
people don't realize you can quit
anytime when you get to the range of
regimen just because you get there
doesn't mean you're gonna guarantee to
stay there if you don't meet uh if you
don't meet the standard if you don't
exceed the standard and they they'll
Haze the [__] out of you so there's
still more even when you get in out of
like 40 dudes that were left over some
of them didn't make it yes so so you get
there you know we all we got our Ranger
tambourne we got our scroll we're like
we thought we're hot [__] I was [__]
20 years old I was like yeah [__] yeah
you know chest puffed out how I thought
it was a [__] got to my unit got [__]
smashed the [__] first day they were
imagine uh a [__] Jaguar those are
the [__] veteran Rangers waiting on
you the [__] deer to come there right
your little rabbit and yeah you know
they're just waiting for you so it's not
like you get the oh my brother no I
thought
it's turned up even more like they smoke
you you are the [__] new guy they
they they're gonna turn up on you and
they're gonna make sure that you meet
the standard and if you don't they're
kicking you in the [__] out they're
sending you back to the [__] big arms
you ever go like why the [__] did I sign
oh my God many times yeah people think
like like people think like you know oh
seen those videos like oh man I've seen
still photo of guys dress all cool
that's like point one percent most of it
is crying most of it is [__] what the
[__] man like guys
oh yeah they're I have another buddy
that's in Special Forces and he told me
his coping mechanism is every school or
every like next thing he gets to because
like you know once you get in there's a
bunch of others going to dive schooling
or whatever school right so every single
one the beginning is always Haze Fest
always so every time he goes in the
first thing he does he assigns a [__]
in his brain he goes okay that guy's a
[__] [__] he goes if the [__] don't
quit I don't quit
what if the [__] quits then yeah he
finds another [__]
yeah who do I think I could take out if
he quits I got equipment
he says you just have to find a way to
cope because it's so [__] hard yeah
you got it and if you do it for yourself
he goes you probably quit on yourself
because it's so there's no point like
you're gonna ride that healthy
competition within somebody yeah so he's
just like you just let someone here is a
[__] [__] you're the [__] who's a
[__] today that's so crazy yeah like we
do the same thing as like when I went
through I was like if somebody [__]
quits it's like another [__] soul
being sucked it's gonna make me [__]
stronger you know what I mean yeah I
felt like you'd be the one
who's the one just give me more power
but the real motivator is like
I know I was going to go to war you know
I want to go I want to go to war with
the best you know what I mean like like
I know like everybody signed the
contract there's no backing out do I
want to go to war with [__] Varsity
or junior varsity I'm gonna [__] go
to war with [__] Varsity dude so I'm
gonna do whatever I can just get on this
[__] varsity team can you say where
you went yeah oh where did you get
deployed first uh I went to mosul Iraq
in 2004 was my first appointment yeah
wow 04 yeah so it was it was man it's
like one of those things that we're on a
C-17 and racing is the back door open
that whiff of air comes in you're like
dude I'm not in America anymore man you
could just smell the like you're in
another [__] foreign country do you
smell like pita and Falafel and yeah
yeah
it smells like [__] Curry
that's nice
because I feel like that when I'm in
Thailand I'm like oh gas and fish sauce
send something yes
very very similar experience I'm sure
that's almost the same all right well on
part two coming up we're gonna get into
what it was like when uh Trump was
deployed uh stay tuned for that
foreign